hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well towards the end
of meditation v Rene Descartes after
providing an ontological argument for
the existence of God and after talking
about the true and immutable natures
that he can know the essences of things
which by the way it fits into that
ontological argument decart is going to
introduce a new set of considerations
that are going to be centrally important
for his project let's remind ourselves
what is his project it's not just to
engage in doubt he is not a skeptic he
wants to use a sort of mitigated
skepticism carefully channeled to erase
all the previous beliefs and then
rebuild them on a solid basis and that
solid basis is provided by the coach ito
by the understanding of the human being
is thinking substance by the argument
for the existence of God and by the
criterion of clear and distinct ideas
that is ideas that I conceive of clearly
and distinctly he says that he can in
fact rely upon those and part of that is
because of the existence of God and the
nature of God is not being a deceiver as
we're going to come to this is going to
allow him in the following meditation to
bring back the external material world
of extended things
including his body and all the things
his body can interact with so this is a
centrally important argument that he is
providing here he tells us after the
argument for the existence of God that
only what I can conceive of clearly and
distinctly can persuade me entirely that
is clear and distinct ideas is what gets
me out of this endless cycle of doubt
and if I didn't have the possibility of
relying upon these as you might say
stable foundations
I really wouldn't be able to get
anywhere because anything that I think
is clear and distinct maybe I'd be wrong
about that and we have to deal with the
fact that as he's pointed out in
meditation for our understandings our
intellects are in fact quite limited so
you know he tells us that what is what
is clear and and distinct is what I can
judge I I you know that I actually know
and then he says that these fall into
two classes of things so he says the the
sorts of things that I conceive of this
type some of them have a truth that is
manifestly or clearly known to anybody
who thinks about them so maybe you don't
think about the nature of a triangle but
when you do you do have to realize that
one angle like in a you know square
triangle the the square triangle that
angle is bigger than the other ones you
don't even have to know much geometry to
figure that out right as a matter of
fact geometry can begin with talking
about that you can say listen children
do you see these angles which one is
bigger now that is something that we
could call in some respect self-evident
it provides its own clear you know clear
and distinct idea to the person who's
considered
and if somebody says I just don't
understand it you can say to them well
look again and we might consider other
ideas along those sorts of lines like
the whole is GRU is greater than anyone
of its parts that might be you know
equally self-evident there's a whole
history of discussions about what is
self-evident in the background of what
Descartes is talking about but then and
this is where it becomes you know very
critical there are a lot of things where
I can come to conceive of them clearly
and distinctly but only after I've made
some sort of effort and only when I
consider them closely or exactly exact a
malt in in French when I'm when I'm
actually paying close attention to them
and here Descartes doesn't just have in
mind things that require us to look at
them closely he's also got in mind
things that rely on some sort of
argument or a chain of evidence being
provided and you know if you think about
mathematical or geometrical proofs that
those provide a great example they can
be quite lengthy and as you're going
through the proof each part of it is
being conceived clearly and distinctly
but you might not grasp the totality of
it and then you get to the end in your
life well I mean I buy into all these
these transformations here so the
results must be right but I don't
completely grasp the totality of what's
going on here Descartes thinks that in
those cases you still can rely upon it
so long as you haven't made any mistake
and the inferences or you know smuggled
in some on you know unclear or false or
dubious premises right so when we're
thinking about the nature of the
triangle again and we consider the three
angles and we let's say we're talking
about a right triangle we know that the
two other angles have to add up to the
same thing as that 90 degree right
angle right that that requires a
demonstration and we might be able to
keep that in our mind all the time but
most of us Descartes included by the way
Descartes was a mathematical genius
so if Descartes can't keep it in his
mind all the time probably most of us
can't we can't keep it in our mind all
the time so we know that we conceived of
it clearly and distinctly at one time we
know that we judged it to be true can we
still rely upon that if we can't then
we're stuck having to like recreate
everything at every single point and the
prospects for attaining any certain
knowledge outside of the sphere of the
coach Ito the myself is thinking
substance or the existence of God
becomes pretty dim doesn't it how are we
going to get get to know the entire
outside world we'd have to become
pessimists so Descartes says that once I
actually have conceived of something
clearly and distinctly I can rely upon
that as a sort of acquisition why I can
trust it and I can make use of it going
forward so think of the results again in
mathematics you prove certain theorems
now you can use those going forward you
might forget how you proved it but you
could always go back and do it again and
see that you didn't make any mistakes
hopefully right I can't always be
considering every single idea that I
have in my mind so how can I be assured
that I can actually trust and make use
of them going forward well there's
there's two parts to the answer to this
two ways of conceiving of this one is I
can remember that I did in fact arrive
at a previous judgment that the thing
was true and if I've been following the
sort of you know you might call it an
ethics of the mind that was laid out in
in the previous meditation
where I don't allow my will to go past
what my intellect clearly and distinctly
conceives of then I can be sure that the
thing was true then and is still going
to be true now if I'm playing fast and
loose however I can't really trust that
now can i and then you know everything
would sort of fall back into these these
doubts I says I would not have a true in
certain science of anything whatever it
may be but only vague and inconstant
opinions so that would be a real problem
for Descartes but he thinks I can't rely
on my memory of having proven it or
discovered it to be true so there's that
but reinforcing that and according to
Descartes really central to this is the
fact that I can rely upon God not being
a deceiver because I have proven the
existence of God as he claims to have
done in meditation v and in meditation 3
and because he has arrived at the
knowledge that God could not be a Seaver
because that would be to lack a
perfection which is incompatible with
the very notion of God as being a being
possessing all perfections I can trust
that the true and immutable natures that
I'm grasping through clear and distinct
ideas are in fact real they are true so
because God is not a deceiver and
because I can rely upon my memory I
don't have to go back and prove
everything once again I can now make
progress so you see how this is really
centrally important to the entire
Cartesian project he doesn't just want
to have knowledge of a few things he
wants to develop science that he can
rely upon and this is going to be a
a central part of that this is one of
the linchpins of the very possibility of
science
you